So Google Vo 3.1 now lets you upload
three reference images. So you can now
create any character in any location
holding any object. You can also use
first and last frame which has now been
integrated into Google V3.1 so you can
create epic transition videos like this.
This is going to be a fascinating one.
So strap in.
Hello and welcome to today's video by
GenHQ. My name is Raw Keith and today
we're going to be looking at the new
Google VO3.1 video model. With this new
model, we've got a few new exciting
features to cover. One is the
ingredients feature that allows you to
upload three reference images, and you
can combine those elements together into
a single video. Next up, we've also got
the first and last frame feature, which
has now been added to the new Google
V3.1 model. This means we can now start
with a start frame and end with an end
frame and the AI will connect the dots
in between those two frames. Now there
are competing products like Clling 2.1
first and last frame for example that
allow you to actually connect those dots
between a first and a last frame very
successfully. But the new advantage of
using Google V3.1 is that we now have
audio and sound design on that first and
last frame. So let's get started. First
things first, we can access the new
model on Higsfield. The main reason why
I'm suggesting Higsfield for this
situation is because obviously we have
unlimited generations for the first week
of release. This means we can play
around with it as much as we want and we
have unlimited credits. It's only
available under some of their
subscriptions, but make sure you check
it out. And you also get unlimited image
generation as well. So I'm going to show
you if we go to the video section at the
top of the page on Higsfield, we can now
have access to Google V3.1.
So in here you'll see on the left hand
side they have both of these features
enabled in their platform. So we have
the frames where we can upload a start
frame and an end frame or just a first
frame if you want to go from image to
video for example. Secondly they've also
got ingredients where you can see here
it says you can upload up to three
reference photos which you can combine
together to create a single video. Now
what's really interesting too is that
they also have this multi-shot mode
feature. Now, I haven't seen any other
platform integrate this yet, and I'm
very happy that Higsfield have because
you'll see here it says it splits your
prompt into scenes and adds camera cuts.
So, with this enabled, it will actually,
if I was to write in a scene of like a
man who is working uh on cleaning uh an
engine inside of a car. The camera cuts
to a closeup of him wiping the sweat
off of his brow. Uh, he then says,
"Damn, this is a hard day's work." Okay,
so let's say we wanted to generate that,
right? So, I'm going to copy this prompt
and we can use a reference photo. And I
have like a couple here for example
where I used Cadream to actually
generate these images. I love using
Cadream as an image model primarily
because of just how good it is at
actually uh creating 4K imagery. So I
love the fact that we get those high
crisp high resolution images. Usually my
recommendation to people uh so we can
hit generate on this right now. Usually
my recommendation to people if you're
trying to elevate your workflow to get
the most out of Google VO in the past
when you were to upload an image into
Google Vo 3, it would actually give you
an output that looked really AI
generated because it often smoothed out
the skin and it would also adjust the
coloring in your scene. with this. Um,
if you can actually upload a really
crisp, high quality image, either one
that is upscaled or just one that has a
lot of details for the video model to
attach to, then you're going to get a
much better output. So, if you're
generating imagery, for example, with a
separate image model, maybe it's Google
Nano Banana, for example, then the
output of your image is going to be a
really low resolution. It's going to be
a,000 by,000 mega pixels roughly. And
what we want to try and reduce is
uploading lowquality imagery to Google
V3 because it's only going to give you
poor outputs. So for example, um I could
also download this image here as well.
We can go back in here um and it looks
like it's giving me an error. So in
order to fix this, I'm just going to
remove the word dam from our prompt here
and let's see if it fixes it. Let's try
it with this new image that we've got
and we can upload that in here.
Sometimes it's getting um a little bit
like funny when it comes to swearing.
So, we've noticed that we try to
generate like have these characters say
some swear words in the past too. Um and
a a lot of the time the generations
actually end up getting blocked. So,
maybe it would just be that word that's
kind of causing us a bit of grief in
this example. This video is now in
progress. So, clearly removing the word
dam was the uh issue with our original
prompt. Now, because I have this
multi-shot feature enabled, you'll see
here it's actually adjusted my prompt,
um, and it's rewritten it in a much more
custom and bespoke way. So, let's open
this up in a Google doc, and we'll
actually see exactly what they, uh, have
adjusted our prompt to. So, an 8second
cinematic video with seamless cuts and
steady camera work. 0 to2 seconds medium
shot on a man leaning over the hood of
the Land Rover.
X, Y, and Zed kind of providing of
details. Two to three seconds, quick cut
to a closeup of his face. 3 to 5
seconds, slow zoom on his face. 5 to 7
seconds, medium shot, pulls back out. 7
to 8 seconds, final shot lingers on the
Land Rover badge um on the engine cover.
So in here, we've got 1 2 3 4 five shots
inside of an 8second sequence. Now I'm
have no idea how it's going to handle
this, but let's have a look.
This is a hard day's work.
>> Wow.
Jesus Christ. Okay, that is impressive.
So, really, it actually ended up doing
one, two,
three,
three videos in the sequence. So, that
was really impressive. Um, overall the
prompt coherence was pretty accurate. I
think I was expecting a couple more, you
know, separate shots. If these were
broken down into all of their
constituents, I would I would have
thought it would have given us a couple
more. Now, let's also investigate the
ingredients feature because this is a
massive massive um upgrade for us as
storytellers. We can use this with
consistent, you know, we can design our
own locations. We can then design our
character and what they're wearing. And
then we can also upload an image of a
product and we can have three separate
images to combine that together. So, for
example, let's design a character that
isn't me and let's come up with that
together. So, under image, I'm going to
use um let's just try Higsfield Soul.
Let's try their own image model. So, um
their head is a television screen and
they're wearing abstract clothing on a
white background. So, some of these
generations are already coming in here.
And I actually really like this one from
Seamream. This character looks really
cool. Details are really crisp. He's
kind of got this like um abstract kind
of feel to him. He's almost like a
cartoon mixed with like it's like a
hybrid between cartoon and realism. So,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
back into Cream here and I'm going to
upload an image of this character. And
I'm then going to say generate me a full
body shot of this character on a white
background.
Um and now we can see also some of these
other image generations are coming
through. Love this uh top that this
guy's wearing. Very cool. But um we're
now going to generate a full body shot
of this character here because I want to
make sure that we can unlock a full
consistency of our character. I'm going
to teach you a few tips and tricks that
you can use in order to unlock character
consistency as well with this new model.
So bear with me and I'm going to show
you a expert level tip as well. So now
we have this image here which represents
the full body of this character. Now
this is just a rough uh representation.
If I was doing this for a specific job
for example, if I was doing client work,
then I would probably go into much more
detail on the character. But just for
the sake of an example here to educate
you with this full image of the
character, we can go back into video
model here. And I'm actually going to
show you this in cling 2.5. So we're
going to now upload this reference photo
of the character that we have just made.
Now I'm going to say the character spins
on a full 360. So we see all angles of
the character. He moves around in a full
rotation.
Okay. And we can use a 10-second
generation for this. And what this does
is it allows us to generate a video of
our character who is then going to spin
in a circle like this. And that allows
us to pause the video and take
screenshots of any part of this video
that we can then use as a reference
photo when we are then um you know
trying to generate a side profile of
this character or a back shot for
example of this character. We will be
able to have a full 360° angle of this
um this character right here by doing
this method. So this is a very very
clever way that you can you know use to
unlock character consistency too.
Amazing. So this video has just loaded
in. So take a look at this. So now we
have this character spinning on a full
360 rotation angle. I can pause this at
any time and use any of these
screenshots to literally have a full 360
render of this character, right? Which
is just perfect. So that's amazing. We
can download that for now. Now, with
this, we can also go back to Google Vo
3.1 here. And now, let's go to the
ingredients feature. So, I'm going to
upload this image of our character here
as you know uh let's just say our
consistent character. Next up, I want to
generate a uh maybe like the an image
which is going to be our location. So,
let's say I want to generate inside of a
car. So, I want to have this character
driving a car and I want it to be like a
cinematic nighttime shot. So, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say
an image of a car and the camera is
positioned outside of the front of the
windshield and it's looking into the car
so we can see the passenger seat and the
driver's seat and there is nobody uh
driving the car. So the car is empty and
uh it is nighttime in the this example
and we can just about see inside the
car.
Okay, I am going to generate this with a
couple of different um image models
again just so that we can get a few
different examples of what we could be
working with. Um and again we'll pick
the best one for our reference image
too. Oh, this is perfect. Okay, so Nano
Banana has done a pretty bangup job.
This is pretty solid. This one's also
pretty solid. I actually quite like both
of these. So, I'm going to download both
for now. Um, so give them both a
download. Now, we can go back to our
video model here. So, inside of
Higsfield, go back to Google Vo 3.1 and
we can upload this location. Uh, as you
can see here, it doesn't matter about
the aspect ratio of your image, by the
way. Um, now I can upload maybe like an
iPhone, for example, because I want this
character to be on the phone while he's
driving. So, I want him to have like one
hand like this. So, he's like holding
the wheel. And I want one hand for this
character to be on the phone. So, let's
just go and find iPhone. The new one is
the 17 Pro, I think. To be honest, I've
personally lost track at this point. Um,
let's do a white one just cuz I feel
like that's going to provide a bit of
contrast for us. Right, this one will
do. It's not even the right way up, but
I'm going to download that and then we
can upload that back as our last
ingredient here. So, with these three
images together, I can now go ahead and
start prompting. So, what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to say the
character who has the TV as the head is
sat inside the car and he is driving the
car. He has one hand on the wheel and
he's holding an iPhone up to his ear and
he is talking. Um, and as he is talking,
the light on the um, TV monitor flickers
um, to visually represent each time he's
talking. And he's in a heated debate
with his girlfriend on the phone. And in
the background, we can hear his
girlfriend talking on the phone and then
he's replying to his girlfriend and he's
getting frustrated.
Hopefully this does a good job. We can
also go in here and we can adjust this
to be 1080p as well for the quality.
Now, I do have to mention I'm going to
generate one in 1080p as well, just so
that you can see. Usually, um, when you
adjust this to 1080p, what it's doing is
it's just upscaling it inside of the
Google V3.1 model. Now, when you do
upscale from 720p up to 1080p, it can
actually negatively impact the
performance of the video. Now, why is
this? It's because when you upscale
videos like that, sometimes it washes
out a lot of the detail in your video.
So, if you have um images of humans that
or you know, videos of humans that
you're trying to generate, it will
actually wash out a lot of the skin
detail and it'll give you that plasticky
look, which is not what we want. We do
not want to be generating videos that
look AI. Maybe that's the look that
you're going for. Um, but in this
example, I'm trying to create like more
cinematic style um kind of content. And
we can also see here it because I have
the multi-shot um uh enabled, we are
able to it's going to take our prompt
and it's going to use a prompt enhancer
on the back end to actually give us this
really nice prompt structure. So you
don't even need to use like a custom GPT
or a custom large language model or
anything like that to actually uh create
good prompts. You can just simply write
in whatever you want and then on the
back end it will handle all of that for
you which is you know very helpful to
have but also sometimes it can like do
uh add in things that you don't want to
be there. So, if that is the case, you
can always turn this off. Um, and you
can prompt in your own things yourself,
for example, where you can say like the
camera cuts to a side profile of the
character talking on the phone. Um, and
it will generate that cut maybe halfway
through the video for you. So, that's
another way that you can do this without
actually needing to enable the
multi-shot mode, but it is nice to have
that there as a feature if you wanted to
use it. So, these generations have
loaded in and you can see them on the
side here. Now, I'm not going to lie,
for whatever reason, Google V3.1 refused
to generate someone who was on the phone
and behind the drivers wheel. Obviously,
they are much more responsible than most
of us are. Now, the last thing that I
want to come on to is the first and last
frame feature. And I'm going to show you
how you can use this in a marketing
sense to help actually showcase your
product in certain scenes. So, let's
dive in. So, to get started, let's
actually create our imagery. So for this
we can simply pick a product for example
and let's choose an image model. So for
this I'm going to choose Nano Banana
because I believe that when you're
uploading images of specific products
which might have text on it for example
using um Nano Banana is probably your
best model. So for this I always like to
use this as an example but I like to use
Kellogg's serial box. Uh serial
box. So, we can use this image here.
We've got the image resolution down
here. It's big enough for me. So, let's
download this one. Now, we can go back
into Higsfield and we can upload this as
a reference image. So, this could be
whatever product that you wanted to
showcase. For example,
on a black uh hue background with slight
tint of orange, I would like you to add
this uh product floating in space in
like a and give it a 3D depth
environment.
Let's adjust the aspect ratio of this to
be portrait as though we're creating
something for social media for example.
Then we can simply hit generate. So
let's generate a bunch of different
examples of this. So, we're generating
eight images.
So, here are our generations. We have
this version here, and we also have this
version here. So, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to download both of these,
and I'm going to show you how we can use
first and last frame to create a really
cool transition. So, if we go back into
Google V3.1, now we can go to the frames
option, and we can upload this as our
first frame. So, maybe this shot here.
And then for our end frame, we can
upload this shot right here. So, what
we're going to do is just upload them in
there. And we can write in a prompt
saying, "The serial is floating in the
air, and the camera slowly moves around
the box. The box slants ever so slightly
as it's floating in the air and orange
particles starts to circle around the
box showcasing a cool product transition
shot. So with that we can add that in
like so. Make sure you have enhance off
and also multi-shot off otherwise it
will change your prompt. And then you
can simply hit generate. Another tip
that you can also do is you could upload
both of these image into a large
language model of your choice and you
can also say write me a simple first and
last frame transition shot between the
close-up image of the serial box to the
last frame which is has the orange
particles swirling around it. In between
these two frames, I would like to have
um the product floating in the air. And
I would like these orange uh particles
to circle around the box, creating a
very cool transition. Can you write me a
prompt that's optimized for Google V3.1?
Then with that, we can simply paste that
into our large language model of choice.
You could use Google Gemini. Uh you
could use Claude, you could use chat
GPT. um whichever one you have a
subscription to. Then um in response you
will get your prompt and it's giving me
a uh a custom prompt here. Um so let's
copy that and we could paste that into
here as well. So here is one of the
examples that we've generated. Take a
look at this. So we've got the product
rotating
and then it adds in this cool transition
effect as well. Now, this is a very very
basic one that you you know that I've
just generated in no time at all. Given
some actual thought and putting some
effort behind it, you can really use
this to come up with some incredible
incredible content that you can use to
help grab the viewers's attention, which
is what marketing is all about. I also
just want to summarize a couple of other
key points that we've learned from
Google V3.1.
Overall, the general prompt coherence
with this new model is significantly
better than the Google V3 output.
Another thing which has been improved is
voices. A lot of the time when you used
Google V3, you would actually get these
really tiny voice outputs. But now it's
been significantly improved with this
new model as well. And again, I will
leave a link to Higsfield in the
description if you wanted to go and use
this as a platform to actually have
unlimited generations and play as much
as you want with the tool, then I'll
leave a link to that down below. If
you're interested in taking creative Gen
AI seriously and turning this into a
professional career, then you can come
and join us over at GenHQ.